depuis plusieurs semaines certains
médecins généralistes font grève ils
demandent notamment une hausse du prix
des consultations également qui
passeraient de 25 à 50 euros pour en
parler Eric Alain Genest bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes médecin alors la hausse du
montant de la consultation qui passerait
de 25 à 50 €, est-ce que pour vous c'est
une bonne solution
ce n'est pas une solution déjà la base
d'abord c'est pas une revendication qui
est portée par l'ensemble de la
profession mais c'est la revendication
qui a été retenue par l'ensemble des
médias on ne parle que de ça alors que
la réalité du mouvement de grève elle
est palliée à une augmentation tarifaire
même si cette augmentation est
parfaitement légitime on est aujourd'hui
les médecins les moins bien payés
d'Europe donc il est tout à fait
légitime non seulement de revaloriser le
montant de cette consultation qui je le
rappelle est notre seul acte le médecin
généraliste n'a pas d'acte technique il
est payé c'est un acte intellectuel et
tout au long de ces dernières années on
a vu une dévalorisation des professions
de vocation et notamment de la quinelle
donc il est parfaitement légitime que
cet axe soit réévalué mais ce n'est pas
la seule revendication
nous ayant le système de santé aller
dans le mur ça fait des années qu'on
tire le signal d'alarme et nous ne
sommes pas entendu
parmi les revendications qui
sous-tendent notre mouvement il y en a
beaucoup qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas
mis en valeur quand on voit que en
Île-de-France plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de patients qui sont en
affection longue durée c'est-à-dire des
gens qui ont des maladies chroniques des
maladies graves n'ont pas de médecins
traitant vous croyez qu'on peut se
satisfaire dans nos professions
j'entendais le boulanger qui veut donner
du bon pain aux Français bah nous on
veut donner des bons soins à nos
patients et on veut que tous nos
patients soient bien soignés donc
l'augmentation du montant de la
consultation c'est pas pour doubler nos
revenus c'est pour prendre plus de temps
parce que nous avons des pathologies de
plus en plus complexes à traiter et
d'autre part aussi le fait que notre
profession soit de moins en moins
attractive fait que nos jeunes collègues
ne s'installent pas et le vrai problème
aujourd'hui n'est pas tellement le
manque de médecin formé c'est le manque
de médecins qui s'installe savez-vous
que l'on forme depuis on a formé depuis
10 ans 45000 médecins seuls 10% se sont
installés alors vous pouvez augmenter le
numerus exclusion autant que vous voulez
tant que cette profession ne sera pas
attractive
ces jeunes médecins ne s'installe pas je
l'explique de manière très simple le
métier n'est plus attractif ces
conditions d'exercice deviennent de plus
en plus complexes quand si vous voulez
on nous dit et ça fait des des décennies
que ça dure que on demande des
simplifications par exemple dans le dans
les tâches administratives on nous dit
bah on va vous permettre d'embaucher des
assistants pour traiter chez tâches
administratives enfin c'est quand même
ridicule pourquoi ne pas supprimer tout
simplement c'est achat administratif moi
je n'ai pas besoin d'un assistant qui va
faire des lettres à la sécu toute la
journée ou régler des problèmes
administratifs j'ai besoin
éventuellement d'un assistant qui met
dans mon travail médical donc si vous
voulez ces fausses bonnes idées qui
consistent à nous à nous proposer de
l'aide pour nos tâches administratives
supprimons-les qu'on consiste à déléguer
à des non médecins des tâches médicales
c'est extrêmement préjudiciable à la
santé de nos patients il n'y a pas de
petites ou de grande médecine il y a la
médecine ça s'apprend dix ans et on ne
peut pas dévoyer comme ça le soin
dégrader l'offre de soins je vous
rappelle quand même que la France est un
des pays qui paye le plus cher pour sa
santé les gens n'ont pas pour leur
argent et ça fait des décennies que ça
dure et ça fait des décennies qu'on le
dénonce et ça fait des décennies que
l'on donne de avec toute la sincérité du
monde de très mauvaises réponses à
d'excellentes questions donc il serait
temps qu'on écoute un petit peu la
profession elle a des choses à dire et
s'il est regrettable si vous voulez que
ne soit mise en avant que l'augmentation
des honoraires de 25 à 50 euros même si
cette augmentation peut paraître
légitime
installation pourrait croire que c'est
une problématique qui touche plutôt la
province mais rien que dans les Yvelines
c'est aussi une réalité bien sûr les
déserts médicaux ont dit il y a des
déserts médicaux en France d'abord avant
les déserts médicaux il y avait des
déserts tout court c'est à dire que s'il
suffisait de planter un médecin pour que
pour faire reculer le désert comme je le
dis on en mettrait un tous les 10 km
dans le Sahara et il y aurait plus de
désert donc déjà si vous voulez l'idée
de dire que moi pendant 20 ans j'ai
entendu dire oui les médecins veulent
s'installer sur la Côte d'Azur c'est pas
vrai il y a aujourd'hui des airs
médicaux sur la Côte d'Azur comme
partout ailleurs la vraie question c'est
pourquoi on a formé 45000 médecins en
disant et pourquoi il y en a que 5000
installés moi c'est ça la vraie raison
et quand tant qu'on ne rendra pas
l'installation attractive tant qu'on
incitera pas nos jeunes collègues à
s'installer et c'est pas avec des
mesures coercitives comme celle que l'on
voit arriver ou des mesures qui
consistent à déléguer des soins que on
va inciter nos collègues à s'installer
voilà alors la Fédération française des
médecins généralistes 11% des patients
de plus de 17 ans n'ont pas de médecins
généralistes et la moyenne nationale est
de 800 patients par médecin vous quel
est votre nombre de quel est votre
patientèle moi je au dernier je regarde
pas ma patientèle tous les jours mais la
dernière fois que j'ai regardé on devait
être autour de 1500
je n'en ai pas vraiment entendu parler
mais je crois que mes collègues sont
plutôt aux alentours de de des chiffres
comme ceux que je viens de citer 1500
entre 1500 millions entre 1300 et 2000
patients voilà en général c'est plutôt
ce ce
chiffre là que que je retiens c'est
assez considérable oui c'est assez
considérable et si on met en place un
certain nombre de dispositions comme
ceux qu'on a entendu par exemple de
déléguer à des infirmiers de pratiquer
avancées des soins sous l'autorité d'un
médecin c'est plus 1500 patients c'est
10000 qu'il va falloir gérer dont plus
des 4/5 qu'on n'aura jamais vu donc si
vous voulez si le système de santé que
l'on paye fort cher aujourd'hui c'est
pour c'est pour arriver à ce niveau de
dégradation nous on n'est pas d'accord
refuser beaucoup aujourd'hui de patients
moi je enfin vous savez c'est très
difficile de dire de refuser moi je ne
refuse pas de recevoir j'étais élevé à
au biberon des soins que l'on doit
donner que l'on doit offrir mais si vous
voulez forcément il y a un certain
nombre de patients qui ne trouvent pas
de réponse alors demande et on voit bien
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui à la maison
médicale de garde de Montigny qui est en
grande souffrance aussi et il faudrait
aussi qu'on puisse en parler ou la
majeure partie des gens qui consultent
en dehors des heures d'ouverture des
cabinets ne consulte pas pour des
problèmes urgent mais parce qu'ils n'ont
pas pu avoir accès à leur médecin
traitant donc des gens viennent le soir
on n'est plus dans de la consultation de
permanence de soi on est dans de la
consultation de nuit ou du week-end ce
qui n'a rien à voir et et sur le nombre
de patients qui augmentent de manière
exponentielle le plus souvent on est
amené à avoir des patients qui n'ont pas
pu consulter leur médecin traitant
des déserts médicaux est très
préoccupants dans les Yvelines vous le
disiez à l'instant Grégory nous sommes
allés demander aux îles Linois s'ils
avaient des difficultés pour trouver des
médecins les propos recueillis par
Julien Leroy et Ludivine canard moi j'ai
pas été confronté directement parce que
moi j'ai la chance d'être suivi par un
médecin depuis plusieurs années et quand
elle est partie à sa retraite ça
remplaçant donc a repris forcément tous
ces dossiers oui j'ai essayé pendant de
vous récemment en janvier du 2
finalement j'ai eu rendez-vous le 9 donc
il y a quand même une semaine de
différence fait en cas d'urgence c'est
vraiment pas comment faire c'est pas
simple non j'ai pas j'ai pas eu de
complications pour pour aller chez le
médecin dans le sens où je suis pas je
suis pas malade mon médecin généraliste
est parti en retraite avec sa collègue
depuis le 31 décembre et depuis donc
c'est un gros gros problème pour trouver
un remplaçant ou une remplaçante je n'ai
pas eu à prendre de rendez-vous pour
l'instant mais mon médecin est parti à
la retraite donc je n'ai plus de médecin
traitant alors j'ai la fille d'une amie
qui fin vous allez de médecine et je
serai une de ses premières patientes
avec mes enfants alors comment comment
remédier à ce manque de médecin avec à
l'injeunesse vous nous expliquer
augmenter l'attractivité du métier mais
est-ce qu'il y a des pistes concrètes
elles viennent du terrain on a donné un
certain nombre d'idées la médecine ne
s'exerce plus comme dans les années 50
ou avant ou il suffisait d'avoir un
stéthoscope et puis une bonne oreille
pour faire de la médecine aujourd'hui la
médecine a besoin de plateau technique
elle a besoin d'accessibilité elle a
aussi besoin de rapport avec l'hôpital
je dirais on a il y a une sorte de
frontière entre la médecine de ville et
l'hôpital il faut rompre cette frontière
nous permettre d'avoir une une
un échange et des dialogues avec nos
collègues hospitaliers qui soient
facilité pour améliorer la prise en
charge de nos patients il y a tout un
toutes ces mesures là si vous voulez qui
sont des mesures de bon sens mais qui
inciteraient nos jeunes collègues à
s'installer il n'est pas normal que
entre 80 et 90% de nos collègues formés
s'installent vous pouvez doubler le
numéro exclusif on aurait au bout du
compte pas plus qui s'installe donc
incitons nos collègues à s'installer
mais pour que les inciter à s'installer
il faut des mesures pour favoriser
l'installation mais il faut surtout
rendre la profession attractive or c'est
exactement le contraire qu'on fait et
depuis des années je n'ai pas encore ce
gouvernement ni les autres ça fait 25
ans depuis les ordonnances Juppé qu'on
casse le système de santé la médecine de
ville il serait temps peut-être
d'inverser la vapeur avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard cette grève
selon vous la fonctionné des choses ont
été dites des manifestations étaient
faites on verra ce que ça donnera dans
les jours suivants moi je ne doute pas
de la bonne volonté lorsque il m'est
arrivé de discuter avec des personnes
qui avaient des responsabilités
politiques les personnes que j'ai en
face de moi étaient sincères
c'est-à-dire que midi mais oui vous avez
ce problème ou à le régler comme ça vous
avez trop de monde et ben on va déléguer
aux pharmaciens on va déléguer des
infirmiers on va laisser l'équilibrer
mais attendez on est où là c'est c'est
la médecine c'est de la médecine c'est
pas de la kinésithérapie c'est pas le
rôle d'une infirmière de faire le
travail du médecin c'est ma mère qui
était de l'ancienne école disait souvent
un proverbe chacun son métier les vaches
sont bien gardés et bien la médecine ça
s'apprend dix ans en étude mais ensuite
il y a toute l'expérience d'une vie et
ça ça ne se remplace pas par de la bonne
volonté même si des personnels peuvent
faire un certain nombre de tâches
médicales je ne dis pas le contraire
mais considérer que on va transformer la
médecine en autre chose et bien ce n'est
pas défendre l'intérêt de nos patients
et nous ce qui nous tient à cœur et les
augmentations d'honoraires c'est non pas
pour gagner plus d'argent c'est pour
passer plus de temps avec nos patients
avoir plus de temps leur consacrer parce
qu'aujourd'hui avec 25 euros de
consultation il faut voir entre trois et
quatre patients à l'heure et ça n'est
pas suffisant donc nous voulons prendre
du temps et nous voulons que nos jeunes
collègues s'installent pour prendre en
charge tous ces patients qui n'ont pas
de médecin traitant et ça c'est possible
il faut rendre le métier attractif il
faut redonner cette lettre de noblesse à
la médecine générale et quand on leur a
fait peut-être qu'à ce moment-là nos
jeunes collègues ont envie de
s'installer de faire ce merveilleux
métier parce que très sincèrement moi
j'ai entendu beaucoup de sirènes aussi
ce n'est autour de moi pour faire autre
chose je suis resté là parce que on fait
un métier formidable et nos collègues le
savent et le partage et ce que nous
voulons faire au travers de ce mouvement
c'est défendre ce merveilleux métier et
donner à nos jeunes collègues envie de
le faire avec nous